greetings from podcastville uncle joey's
joint
is brought to you by draftkings
we're here in dirty jersey but it don't
matter
it's a season for [__] giving but for
you
it's for the taking you understand me
like i told you the other day
you you ain't waking up unless
somebody's paying you and here it is
draftking is coming in with jingle bells
and dropping [__] gifts
they've got odd boost promotions and the
best lines in the nfl
ncaa basketball football and ufc
every single day this week plus endless
ways to get
on the action bet live on your favorite
[__] player
and if you sign up now today wednesday
you get a chance to triple you heard it
right here one time
triple triple your winnings when you
make any bet
on the ufc fight this saturday night
figaro dodo whatever his [__] name is
against moreno
you think i'm [__] smoking too much
dope no
and get three times any bet
on any bet the umc
256. and listen don't worry about
saturday
because the party starts tonight if you
sign up today you get a grand bonus
with code joey that's all you need
you're going to get a grand today
you understand me look at tonight you
got some great games you got michigan
state versus virginia
you got wisconsin versus louisville the
party starts
tonight [__] tomorrow i think
you got nfl football
friday you got college basketball and
then sadly
listen you got tony ferguson against
[__] charles oliveira
you got mackenzie dern in that badass of
us
you got jacqueline you got junior dos
santos
plus you got the headline finger relato
against [__] moreno
so do yourself a favor right now
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app
use promo code joey when you sign up and
get up to a thousand dollars
you heard it right now a thousand
[__] dollars
that's code joey for limited time only
at draftkings sports book
and here's the part the lawyers make me
say all right you got to be 21 or older
don't [__] around new jersey
and it's got to be new jersey indiana
pennsylvania but now we've added some
states
like tennessee's got gambling colorado's
got gambling
so you're in [__] the deposit
bonus requires a 25 times play through
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details but if you got a
gambling problem if you're a [__]
degenerate
there's help call 1-800 gambler
or if you're in indiana call 1-809
with it if you don't have a gammon
problem like pink said
it's time to get the party started [__]
download the draftking sports app
use code joey and the party starts
tonight
with michigan state virginia and
wisconsin
i think they're playing louisville you
got to check it and [__] like that i
don't know
i don't have a computer back here the
joint is also brought to you by
[__] cbd lion with a chocolate
full spectrum dark chocolate which is
good for you too people say you should
eat dark chocolate once a week
not eat a [__] pie you fat [__]
anyway
cbd lions got it all kinesiology tape
vape pen a roll on a [__] cream
gummy bears tinctures listen if you want
if you really want the benefits of cbd
cbd line got them for you okay it
touched by going to cbdlion.com
read about cbd read about cbd get
knowledgeable about cbd
you may have something that's bothering
you you may have anxiety maybe your
shoulders are stiff
cbd might be able to help you might be
the answer you're looking for
but it all starts with you by going to
cbdline.com
and reading the third party lab results
go to cbd line
they got a sale going on they're [__]
tremendous
at the end you check out you press joey
you press church
ah press whatever the [__] you want to
press and then and they're gonna give
you 20
off delivered right to your [__]
house who takes care of you like uncle
joey
nobody [__] all right cbdlion.com
let's get this [__] party started
look at this wig it's all the way down i
need like [__]
skinny [__] fingers together but look
from all my years of being a pickpocket
let's get this party started
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
wednesday the 9th of december well what
[__] 16 days away from christmas
welcome to uncle joey's joint it's a
beautiful [__] day to be alive
i made it i'm alive i [__] stressed
out all weekend about getting that
[__] pre-op
and it's so funny whenever i have to go
to a [__] hospital
or a doctor's office the whole [__]
night before i'm [__] [__]
pickles
i mean i'm [__] [__] pickles i i
my body breaks down it's the weirdest
thing i had to go to this pre-op thing
right monday tuesday yesterday whatever
the [__]
and uh tuesday yeah today's wednesday
tuesday
with this [__] thing you forget what
day it is sometimes i'm sorry
and i had to go to this pre-op thing let
me tell you something i was supposed to
go like on saturday
and i never [__] went like sadly i
just wasn't prepared
jimmy florentine even offered to drive
me down there it was like a 20-minute
ride
and you can't eat anything you got to
drive on an empty stomach
and when i drive on an empty stomach for
a long time i usually get [__] dizzy
my blood sugar drops and i puke so i'm
like [__] i gotta contend with this [__]
now
and then they're gonna take blood out
and it's a first person like listen if i
gotta give blood
like when i was living in la i went to
bob hope medical center right
bob hope dope bob hope medical center i
would go down there
and there was this nice little black
woman that would take my blood out
great she'd been the same woman for
[__] 10 years
i got used to it she'd call me baby the
whole [__] thing
i'd lay on the [__] thing remember i
don't give blood there's no windows in
the room
so you got to get [__] there's got to
be a window
or if not i start to [__] panic i
started thinking about all that [__]
i had to give blood to a new person you
know i don't know if they're gonna have
a window in the room
and i'm gonna have to have a [__]
face mask on listen i don't know about
you guys
as soon as i get out of my car and i put
a face mask on to go into a building
i swear to god even today even in my
month nine
my anxiety goes up a little bit i swear
to god
those first 10 steps when your air isn't
going into you whatever
i swear to god i get a little bit of
[__] anxiety
still so i'm like i gotta get blood with
a [__] mask on
oh so [__] tuesday my daughter
dropped her off earlier
my wife dropped my daughter off earlier
and we shot down to the hospital
and here's the thing you ready for this
one this is how bad i was
one day i did the podcast with mike
mike left i read a couple of [__]
errands mike you were here with me did i
do any edibles on monday
not in my there's no and i even have the
spray right
so it's easily then i got pills i got
the [__] uh
pro tabs and i got the abx's
right so monday i didn't have nothing
monday night
what am i gonna do monday night football
maybe i'll do this maybe i'll go to my
buddy joe rails whatever the [__]
i'm sitting there and i gotta tell you
at four o'clock
on the [__] computer i was trying to
write material
it must remember the other day i told
you i had a friend that whenever he
would write jokes the
the notebook would boom maybe my
material was so bad that the [__]
notebook hypnotized me and put me to
sleep
i swear to [__] god i'm trying to
write these [__] jokes on you know
nexium and all this [__]
and all of a sudden guys i can't keep it
together i mean guys
i cannot keep it [__] together i'm
getting dizzy and [__] i'm like why am i
so [__] tired
i gotta stop eating these [__]
edibles right so
i go upstairs i tell my wife this i go i
don't know i just got a little bob like
i'm
i'm tired so she goes relax watching tv
for a while
and then go back to do what you were
doing i sat down at 4 30
i slept straight till 6 30.
then i got up i ate dinner i went back
on the chair
and went puts again i went to puts till
30 at night i woke up i ran i gave mercy
a kiss
and i just crawled into bed no [__]
tea
no sleep spread no nothing and i slept
solid till three in the [__] morning
and then i woke up and i was
[__] starving but you can't eat
because you gotta give a [__] blood
test
you can't [__] eat you can't drink
nothing i could even drink [__]
coffee
so i stayed up from three in the morning
till about six
and that uh probably quarter to six i
said let me close my eyes i fell asleep
till about seven
and then she woke me up i washed my
[__] i was sitting here well you know
i'm smelling bacon upstairs and sausage
for mercy
and i'm down there i can't get high ah
you can't get stoned either
so i went down and when i got there i
was the first online and perfect
uh the [__] lady was talking to me i
didn't know what the [__] she was saying
because i can't hear with the with the
mask on i couldn't hear her she couldn't
hear me
and the next thing you know i'm sitting
i turn around and there's [__] 80
people behind me i go
holy [__] i'm happy i came when i did
and when you do a pre-op you got to do a
[__]
you know uh uh the thing for your checks
the the ibm whatever the [__]
i don't know ics the akg whatever the
[__] it is
you gotta do a [__] urine test you
gotta do a blood test
and they gotta do a [__] x-rays on
your lungs
some lady goes you gotta do all these
things so two of them are gonna be done
over there
and the other two are gonna be done over
there the uh the ekg
and the [__] the the [__]
uh x-rays are gonna be done over there
and the blood work
and the pits are gonna be done over
there go over there first
my dum dum [__] so i walk over to give
blood i look in there guys
and it's packed and you know if you read
the art of war the war of art
the war of art it's a thing called
resistance
you know i took a chair i go up to the
lady i'm here she goes all right
you know sign in you're gonna do a blood
test she gave me a jaw
she goes go take the piss test if you
want now and then wait to get called
so i go back there immediately my
[__] blood pressure goes up
you know i got a piss with a mask on i
gotta pull my sweatshirt up
i got jeans on i gotta pull my dick out
make sure i hit the [__]
thing and the p don't splash on your
pants you know
you don't want to [__] smell like pee
so i'd take my dick out even longer and
shrug it out
and put it in the [__] cup and make
sure i peed
and then you don't know how much p's in
there so you got to keep looking at it
and looking at it
and then you just and then you look at
it it's just [__]
three inches of brown [__] i didn't
smell it i didn't even want to smell it
i could smell it in the [__] ass
i put the cap back on and i put in the
baggie boom i give it to her
and i'm sitting there and it had to be
15 [__] minutes guys
and every [__] minute that went by
hey listen
i'm normal just like you guys i i
believe when i get cut
and i put my pants on one leg at a time
every [__] minute i sat there
i gave myself another reason not to have
the surgery have you ever done that
just giving yourself reasons not to do
something that's called resistance
i was sitting there going what am i
doing this
november 18th it's going to ruin my
christmas
you know what christmas what am i one of
santa's helpers
what am i on the [__] sleigh am i
going to help him with the [__]
sleigh rides i mean this is the [__]
that goes in your head you know
i won't be able to give people hugs i
won't be able to do this i won't be able
to do that
i gotta lay down for three days you know
i got to do a show on the 23rd
remember i'm doing surgery on the 18th
but i'm doing a show on the 23rd because
that's how we roll
i'm going to sit on a [__] stool you
know do i really need to do that
[__] it let's do it next year i'll have
the other insurance from sag
i gave myself every reason and i swear
to god guys
this always happens to me i said to
myself you know what
if they don't call my name next i'm
gonna just get up and get the [__] out
of here
and i'll deal with my wife i'll deal
with the doctors you know
and i feel like [__] because i i'm a
[__] and i don't want to take a blood
test
and i didn't even get that process i
didn't even get that thought process
and as usual a guy came
in maybe 10 years younger than me
with the [__] you know the [__]
stroller
and he was breathing heavy his hair was
all [__] up
and when he got to the counter he
basically turned the [__] thing
around
and he sat on the chair and he just sat
there
and the ladies like can i help you and
he's like i just got to get my breath
for a second he walked from the [__]
from the hospital door to there i could
do that that walk was 20 feet
even me with my [__] up legs could do
it but i saw the look on his face i saw
how he sat down
i saw how he was breathing he had sweats
on
he didn't have a wedding band on i
looked at him
and i didn't judge i just broke him down
for who he was
he had a [__] giant shirt on you know
that was two sizes too small for him
he had one roll after the other what i'm
trying to say is
this guy didn't take care of himself and
now he's walking with this [__] thing
you know he never exercised he never
[__]
ate right he never did nothing and i saw
that
when he walked in and i'm like
that's what i don't want you know the
reason i'm doing this knee surgery
the real reason i mean i'm not doing it
to be a [__] fighter
or to run marathons i'm doing it because
i'm embarrassed
i'm embarrassed that when i went to
disneyland last year
i'm embarrassed i went i went to great
adventure this year
i can't walk around my daughter i can't
do that whole [__]
eight mile [__] jaunt around the park
my [__] legs
feel like that you know so i called my
sister i'm like what do you think i
should do because she's like my doctor
my sister's a high level nurse and i
call her for all my advice she's like my
underboss for my
like my conciliati i called her up and i
go listen this is what's going on i'm
like it's the heater cover season
nobody wants to be in a hospital you get
put on the wrong floor or whatever
but at the same time i want to have a
normal summer next year
like i want to be able to walk on the
boardwalk who knows when this is coming
back
but i still gotta walk i mean it's not
like i'm getting it done because i gotta
go [__] load trucks or something
but you know i'm going i'm gonna be 58
in [__] february
we ain't got no younger here my uncle
recommended it
when i talked to my sister i go you know
i don't know she goes why are you doing
it
how bad is the pain like oh the pain is
pretty [__] bad in my knee
you know like if i flip it when i'm
driving because that's the speed pedal
when i flip it if i flip it i gotta like
[__] close my eyes and pull my leg
that's how much pain there is in my
right knee right now even though my left
knee
arthritis wise is worse than my right
so that's the real reason why i'm doing
the surgery you know i go to the gym i
can't walk on the tread i can walk eight
minutes on the treadmill i gotta tap
seven minutes i gotta tap
but i still do all my squats i still do
deadlifts
i still do you know whatever i gotta do
you gotta bend your [__] knee
so i'm able to do it i can live with
that but
what it's really needed for what good is
all that training
if i can't [__] walk five miles and
make my wife
my daughter happy and walk in an
amusement park with her or go on a hike
with her you know that's what i
can't do and i can't be one of those
[__] dads it just sits there
you know they think i'm sitting there
because i'm a fat [__] no
i'm sitting there because my [__]
knees hurt so
the surgery is next [__] friday
that's it and that's that i'm gonna sit
tight i'm gonna see how the [__]
uh therapy goes the physical therapy
i already talked to the guys at the gym
they're ready for me
they've their psychology is listen
you're missing one limb you still got
three other ones
we'll work those and we'll catch the
other one up when it's time
so i'm gonna go for it and then if let's
see what happens in february
[__] they haven't made a decision yet
or whatever the [__] going on
i go back for another knee replacement
and we balance it out
we fix that [__] hamstring and this
is what it's all about right now it's
time for taking care of yourself
you're paying [__] 18 000 months 18
000 a month for insurance you might as
well [__] use it right now
do that colonoscopy get that eye exam
you know
you might as well do all this [__] i got
all the i've got a heart doctor
i can't see at night when i drive i'm
getting the glasses for [__] driving
at night
this is what you do now there's nothing
else to do you might as well take
advantage of it
right or wrong who the [__] am i that's
it we're here
we're [__] queer i was thinking about
something the other day
that you know i've just been thinking
about a lot of [__] lately you know
just the other day i mentioned the dopey
podcast
i have a lot of friends who are sober
who are very sober
who listen to the dopey pie just just
because i smoke pot
and i'm [__] crazy and i'm out of my
mind doesn't mean i don't support sober
people i really do
and uh there's one guy talked to
all the [__] time in fact him and i
do like a [__] mini aaa meeting on
the phone
i've been friends with this guy maybe 30
years
he's been clean for about uh
if i haven't done coke for 13 years
he's probably been clean about 20 years
when i was thinking about
getting clean i didn't talk to nobody
else
but him on a confidential type thing i
would just call him up and explain to
him
this is what i wanted to do and he would
suggest different things that i would do
you know
and uh you know he was the one i
suggested i should go to a little rehab
so i tried to sign up for a [__]
rehab and somebody pointed me out and
they go you were comedian at the comedy
store so i couldn't go back it was like
a little
uh outpatient uh rehab by hollywood
they paid for it i think the state paid
for it or whatever you had to pay a
couple dollars a month
i think it was going to cost like 40
bucks a month i quit after one month but
i learned something
in that one month or the one week or the
two weeks that i was there
i learned a crucial word and it helped
me make my progression into sobriety i
know a lot of people right now are
drinking
i know a lot of people right now doing
[__] drugs
i know a lot of people right now you
know anxiety is big we're going over the
top with the pills
you know i was guilty of that early on
in march and april
uh i didn't enjoy it i didn't like that
i liked the [__] you know the
whatever collapse i had a pan
to relax me it worked but i didn't like
the effect i think it promoted it it was
like when i put my hearing aids in
if i wear my hearing aids too much and i
take them off i'm [__] deaf
why because something else is working
for you it's like doing steroids when
you're old
you know you stop making [__] ball
juice so while you're doing the [__]
steroids all those month
your nutsack ain't making ball juice
then when you get off the steroids now
your body has to reteach itself how to
do all this stuff
but he used that word transfer of
addiction and he also told me that
when people quit getting high they're
addicted
that's why so many people od you know
because well there's two reasons why i
shouldn't say that
there's the reason that they get clean
and they think that they can still
shoot what they were shooting before
they got high
and the other reason why people die is
because it's they take a they take time
off yeah it's the same thing
they [__] do the amount they thought
they could do
six months earlier but they don't know
that their addiction grows
your addiction grows so sometimes you
shoot that amount
and it isn't that the second dose gets
you so either way
your addiction keeps growing that's why
when people quit drinking for 20 years
and they go back up to 20 years they end
up dead because they just drink
everything
in sight i had a friend who just passed
like that he was sober for 20 years
got back on the bottle and [__]
it's over but to shout and uh rest in
peace but
here's what i wanted to get to you for
me when i heard that transfer addiction
it made a lot of sense
because i looked at my own life and i
looked at the addictions i had gone
through and didn't necessarily have to
be drugs
okay we're all addicted to something
along the way at least i was having
addictive personality
once you come to terms that you have an
addictive [__] personality
you go i gotta do something about it i
realize i had an addictive personality
when i was
44 years old it was a bit too late you
know what i'm saying
that's when i broke it down backwards
once i was 44
and i got an addictive [__]
personality
this is what the [__] thing is you
know once you
you try to get clean the first couple
days of you getting clean
are so important for you to journal
those
[__] days you should just be
journaling all day
you know maybe journaling about how you
started getting high
just to relieve the pain of you you know
coming off the [__] [__] you know
for me the journaling when i first got
sober that that first month
that's all i did i remember i was
shooting a movie and i even brought a
notebook and a pad with me to bring on
the [__] set because i would get
cravings
and i would try to give myself excuses
no no one way or another is stuck
and i just stayed sober but
i still remember thinking about the aaa
model
sorry about that the water went down the
wrong tube
it went down the pubic head tube you
know what i'm saying you have to have
that look
pubic hair [__] catch on your neck
that's been a long time i don't even
need that catch no more
i'm not an animal like i used to be but
when i thought about my sobriety i
remember thinking that
[__] i'm not gonna be funny if i don't
get high no more because there were a
couple comics
that [__] stopped getting high and
then they weren't funny because they
took it too seriously
they took the whole sobriety thing a
little bit too seriously which you have
to take
you have to take seriously if you want
to live
people know when they're gonna when
they're garnished me
i knew i was a ghana either day when you
do a line of coke and you're gonna let
an electronic twitch in your [__]
neck
when your neck starts twitching you know
it's just a matter of time before your
brain blows up
you have an aneurysm when you have a
stroke or whatever the [__] happens when
you do coke
so for me between the 400 pounds
the four packs of cigarettes to eating
like an animal
and the electrical twitch is going on
the firework display
i had going off in my spine i figured it
was time to [__] quit
but i knew that if i didn't do something
else
i knew that word transfer of addiction i
knew if i didn't do anything else
that i would end up snorting coke again
and i still remember like three or four
days
like i stopped snorting coke like on an
off day like a tuesday or wednesday
but the true test was going to be that
first weekend of not getting high
and i remembered that i was sticking to
the aaa
prototype which is no reefer either
you can smoke cigarettes and drink all
the coffee you want until your [__]
tongue turns [__] blue
but there's no [__] reefer so i
remember the first three days
of four days i was working on this movie
and i was so caught up that there was
really no refurb in my life
at all you know i would come home and in
those days i got a friend of mine to
give me some
sleeping pill he had he was a neighbor
three doors down
i didn't care about the sleep apnea or
anything the [__]
the whatever the you know the coming off
the coke
at eight o'clock would give me huge
panic attacks
because by eight o'clock i wanted it in
my pocket i didn't want to do it
i want it in my pocket by eight o'clock
so by a quarter of the [__] eight at
night my anxiety would start
[__] percolating so those days i
would just come home
i think a neighbor had valiums a little
black dude in my building had valiums
and i traded them something for valiums
and you know by that time i well i
wasn't eating valium so i knew
half a valium would knock me the [__]
out i'm not gonna lie to you the first
two weeks
of me coming home from that movie at
night i would basically
gonna take a shower i would say the
minimal amount of worries to my wife
because i didn't want
the craving thoughts to get into my head
i would pop a [__] valium
and drink an amaretto and milk how much
of a [__] of a drink is that
but amaretto [__] me up because i don't
drink and i would just [__] soothe
out
and go to bed so i'm thinking to myself
jesus christ joey you're trying to get
[__] sober
and you're still using alcohol and
you know a sleeping pill which is
illegal
to get [__] soap or something didn't
sound right there
but i started thinking about it
what put me in prison cocaine
what made me become a [__] thief like
listen i'm a thief it's in your [__]
dna
but thievery who made me go all out
and be a scumbag thief cocaine
who made me change the way i thought
changed my you know there was a time
period when
i didn't think i could have a good time
at night
unless i i i did coke can you imagine
that
when i was 19 i was already dead in my
mind
if i didn't have coke i didn't think i
would have a good time
people would say to me do you want to go
to this party you're going to have coke
no
i'm not going to that party it's not
going to be fun so when you're training
a thought of that
is that way you're never going to get
out of that i mean that was my
since day one that was my whole thing
you know i didn't
use the coke to get on stage i used the
coke for
after i got off stage to [__] get
high and have a good
at least i had that control i had that
much [__] control
but i'd never forget that first weekend
that i was sober ralphie picked me up
and won the [__] car and you know i
didn't want to tell ralphie i quit doing
coke
i when i do things like that i usually
don't tell people about them
in case i fail so i don't look like a
[__] idiot
you know it's like when i first joined
jiu jitsu
i didn't tell anybody i was joining
because i feel like a [__]
if you quit then you're a failure so
when i first
started not doing coke i didn't say
anything to anybody
i just kept it to myself like the first
maybe 30 days i think sometime in
december i remember that
that's when i [__] realized i was
sober for 30 days i might as well
not do it again it's been the first time
i was sober for 30 days
off cocaine in [__] years i mean the
only time i was ever sober from cocaine
was
august of 88 to february of 88
six months from [__] october of 79
to november of 88 i said of 2007
that's a lot of [__] years of getting
high
you know people say that they lose their
sense of smell when they get covered i'm
surprised i still have
a [__] sense of smell from not
numbing all the [__] things that make
you
smell stuff in your nose i'm really
surprised but
i'm in my smoke department ralphie that
saturday
i felt like a little bit of a hypocrite
but i didn't
sunday i smoked pot monday i smoked pot
and i think when i was a week
sober off cocaine that's when i decided
i said this is going to be called the
transfer of addiction
i'm going to take this and i'm never
going to do coke again
but i'm still going to smoke dope why
because it keeps my [__] powder dry
i don't want to be an itchy guy you know
listen jehovah witnesses bother me
amway salesman bother me and [__]
people who [__]
do so but bother me you ever have
somebody who's too sober
that comes to you and tries to give you
a [__] hear beating
those [__] people bother me you know
they try to like imposing on you
i'm not imposing being sobriety on you
i'm not
at all i want you to be happy live your
life how you living
and do what you do what i'm talking to
you about is if after this pandemic or
right now listen around this time of the
year i get i start thinking about
december 31st
i start thinking about the how much how
how are we going to be
better on december 31st for the for the
next upcoming year
this month is done this year is done
listen i don't want to hear how it was a
bad year was a bad year for everybody
not just for you
nobody had it out for you nobody's gonna
[__] you know
what this is just a bad year and we
gotta pick ourselves up
and dust ourselves the [__] off look in
the mirror and go am i gonna [__] sit
here wounded
or am i gonna [__] move forward we're
gonna move the [__] forward so
you know part of moving forward is these
bad habits we picked up over the last
nine months
and trust me i picked them the [__] up
too but look at me now
look at me now look at my eyeballs
they're clear i'm not
this [__] thing they aren't green no
more over this
i'm not saying that was from doing drugs
but doing [__]
800 milligrams of edibles every day
doesn't help you either
especially when you're taking anxiety
medication and god knows what the [__]
else i was taking so
now i feel a lot better did i put work
into this sobriety no
i just went back to what i was doing
from day one
with smoking pot that said you know what
like i told somebody that day they're
like
do you smoke a lot and i go i'm gonna be
as long as i can with you
during this pandemic there was times
the first march in april the only way i
got through this was
by doing strong edibles now i'm using
the edibles to sleep
i'm not even using the edibles to get
high no more what the [__] for
i mean i'm satisfied with the weed i
moved from california i wanted to change
some stuff around
this is what i wanted to change around
and we did it we're here we're queer
that's it so if you're thinking about
getting sober
and you don't want the pressure like
i've said it a thousand times
i don't give a [__] and i'll prove it to
you [__]
you know those pills you're taking those
abx
pills that i [__] squeeze in my tea
at night those
abx whether they're 50 milligrams
or 100 milligrams you know me give it a
try
don't take it from me tell your best
friend that smokes weed
to make you a platter of brownies give
them whatever you pay for a [__] oxy
cotton
or whatever you pay for those pills
start eating those [__] edibles it's
a complete different feeling i'll tell
you what
you eat one of my [__] abx edibles
you look at those
trust me one time i had an oxycontin a
[__] 16th a little tiny tiny italian
it was small in a baby's tooth it was
tiny little piece
and i felt like [__] and i know when you
eat these edibles
listen and so what if people go to you
yeah but
you're not sober but i'm not gonna
[__] die either
i'm not gonna die either that's my
mentality
you know reefer never got me in [__]
jail one time
i got arrested for a refund i got
spanked in the hand
reefer and the words of chris rock
doesn't make you go to the atm at four
in the [__] morning
reefer doesn't sorry reefer doesn't make
you
reef i gave you guys a thing about
mistake
what the [__] is going on jones reefer
didn't make me rob
houses refor us and give you those story
briefing never made me kidnap somebody
i never kidnapped somebody for a [__]
pound the reefer
so in my world it was the safest place i
could be
what's this so what's the worst thing
that could happen to you when you eat an
edible
you might eat a bag of donuts or you
might pass the [__] out that's the worst
thing that could happen to you
right because you get really [__]
high i don't drive nowhere
you can't get a dwi i mean i know if i
want 20 white castles i go to white
castle
and i'll bring him home then i'll get
high then i'll [__] reheat the white
castles and even
i'm not saying i'm eating white castles
i'm just giving you a [__] example
that you know reefer don't get in no
trouble
i don't give a [__] when anybody tells
you oh it makes you lazy
really come over to my house see what i
do before i smoke a joint
and see what i do after i smoke a joint
you'll be [__] amazed
you're like you do all this [__] i smoke
that [__] and i'm passed out for [__]
20 [__] years
get it together it's called transfer of
addiction
this all started with me and the
pacifier it went from the pacifier to
sodas
it went from [__] sodas to cocaine
and then when i was on cocaine the
addiction spreads to everything else
i was addicted to food i was addicted to
[__] peanut butter again
you transfer that addiction now when i
want a snack
and i want a salami sandwich with cheese
i eat one of those [__] protein bars
it tastes like 10 dead dicks
and they get stuck in your teeth you
have those protein bars
it's like you're eating [__] cork you
got to drink water so you don't choke
the deck
because the [__] thing will [__]
blows up in your throat i'd rather eat a
protein bar that's a chance i gotta
think
that's the same thing with the
addictions it's real easy for me to go
upstairs right now
smoke a joint put a spoon in the [__]
jar of peanut butter
and eat [__] the whole jar of peanut
butter that's my [__] world people
oh and you get how about when you get
the you know i do
you ever get oreos and put them in
[__] peanut butter and [__] like that
you know i've done all that [__] i
didn't get to be a fat [__] because
i was eating [__] tofu burgers and
[__] i got to be a fat [__] because i
know how to throw down
but i also looked at it and acknowledged
and said i can't
keep living like that no more the other
day i went into a [__] wawa
they got [__] new york super fudge
chunk
i almost lost my [__] mind there's
nothing better in this world than tom
and jerry's new york super fight shot
with a big [__] thing that's the
coca-cola you get a super fight chunk
you
eat put half of it put in a big [__]
glass pour coca-cola on it
and stir that [__] and then you
drink it and at the end you get all the
peanuts and the almonds and the [__]
white chocolates in there i love all
that [__] if i do that now
end up in a diabetic [__] dead zone
and who's getting hit the worst from
this covert thing
the diabetic people are [__] going
fast so
if you got diabetes you can't be eating
that [__] sugar
and so i learned from my brother dean
delray
switched to a [__] protein bar it's
the same thing every addiction
has an answer at the end you know what
i'm saying if you're addicted on [__]
12 pizzas you got to find something else
that'll [__] calm that whatever down
you know weight watchers says eat a
[__] apple
you know if you're not hungry enough for
an apple you're not hungry if you're not
hungry enough to eat an apple you're not
really hungry
so you know the addiction could always
be turned down
turned down to what's not going to kill
you that's what i did
listen the coke was going to kill me the
coke was gonna put me in jail
the coke was gonna make me miss [__]
dates how many dates do i miss when i
get stoned
not many how can you forget to get on a
[__] plane you know what i'm saying
when i was too cooked up
there were nights i'd get coked up and i
couldn't get on a [__] plane
so i picked the easiest out of all of
them
something with the reefer so if you get
mad at that type of sobriety go [__]
yourself
it works for uncle joey it keeps my
powder dry and it puts a smile on my
face
and at the end of the week in the words
of sheryl crow
if it makes you happy it can't be that
bad you know what i'm saying
who the [__] do you think you're dealing
with cop suckers it's wednesday the 9th
i'm going to christmas [__] spirit
i'm quoting the great stuff we ain't
[__] around today i feel good
you feel good you look good i can see
you through the [__] screen
constructor
you sit there at your desk with your
hair all [__] up
[__] that [__] go put some mop that duke
sucker
you might get a check on the computer
because it's your lucky week
[__] what else i've been
thinking about lately isn't
something else that was on my mind you
know i'm unwinding
from my [__] la [__]
uh that's why i think i feel
as good as i do and the other night i
was right
and a name just popped up in a journal
you know
just i was writing about something and
about l.a
and what things i miss about i think i
talked to theo that night
and a name popped up you know what name
popped up the other day
just off the blue when i was writing in
the journal
because it really [__] bothered me
and it really opened my eyes
to what i was living through and if i
tell you this i could explain
a lot more things to you by explaining
this to you
two words jessie smilette
have you ever thought about jesse
smellette
and with that poor kid because that's
what i call i'm not mad at jessie
smellette
at all jesse smelled as a young kid
that made the same mistake i made he
tried to set up he just made a mistake
and most of us make mistakes you know
he made a mistake by trying to set up a
fake racial attack
in chicago to make more money to get a
raise
or something he was scared of getting
fired
so he figured if he got beat up they
would feel bad for him and keep him
and i think he was making 75 000 a week
you know this is in the middle of or at
the end of all the weinstein stuff
so i was thinking about the weinstein
stuff and
you know him being accused of rape and
doing time
but all the women that you know sucked
his dick for a movie role
and all that [__]
you know and i was thinking about what
happened you know for you people that
that
are still saying and sure we got in
trouble joining in joe
some [__] jerk call [__] made a a
thing that [__]
rogan laughed in a video and i said 20
chicks
and at the end it was just taken out of
content nobody got in trouble
if we got in trouble i would have been
under a [__] jail right now
nobody got in trouble just a couple of
[__] got upset
and we had to set them straight and let
them know that we're from the lenny
bruce school of comedy
and dick sucking is allowed you
understand me i don't want to hear
nothing
but when you hear the jesse smallette
the argument that happens about justice
millet
you'll understand the dick sucking this
and the whole thing like that
what would make i mean the jesse
smallette situation
is an embarrassing day for men women
gay people whatever the [__] you want to
call it you know some people were saying
he did it because it was gay
you're a [__] [__] he did it
because of the same reason
what turned me off about l.a and that
was it that was the first time
i actually thought about where i was
living and what would make
a good-looking young man with a
great [__] future do something
as [__] stupid because when you look
at the whole [__] thing
it was stupid it was joey diaz
kidnapping stupid it was that stupid
when i look at that point in my life it
was just a stupid [__] day was it fun
it was kind of fun
i had a good time you know [__]
whipping out a gun and
ripping the ceiling down it was fun to
an extent
but when you look at the whole frame of
things and you look at what i did now i
did it
it was [__] stupid [__] stupid
with jessie moletus smallett whatever
his [__] name was
was [__] stupid you look at the kid
you know he's was brought up right he's
educated
you know he was brought up in a good
house
he's not like you know some [__] uh
i i don't know i don't know what to say
anything i'll say i'll get in trouble
which i really don't give a [__] at this
point in the game he's not some [__]
ghetto [__]
uh brother he he's an educated
you know nice trimmed up brother you
know what i'm saying what would make him
set up an attack say that two black guys
attacked them and
yelled trump or some [__] you know
as they beat them up they're like [__]
you trump sent us
whatever the [__] i don't know what they
said to him
but you know no joke what would make
somebody
make up a story like that put themselves
in a situation
it's not the greed it was the
desperation
the same desperation those women had
when they walked up the [__] stands
with harvey
you know and then he you got a 50 50
chance
you know a lot of people didn't suck
harvey's dick but a lot of women did
suck harvey's dick
and someday that memoir is gonna come
out and not that it matters
you know you gotta do whatever you gotta
do to take you to where you need to be
i'm not here to judge you whatever but
don't play like you didn't know what was
gonna happen
while you were going up that elevator or
while you were walking up those steps
that's what [__] bothers me but
that's not the subject i'm talking about
here
i'm talking about jessie smallette and
the [__] move he did
and you're sitting there going joey yeah
but that happened almost a year ago
that's why it's good to bring it up now
because back then you weren't thinking
when you first got hit with it
it's like the people who first got hit
with you know when the guy got beat up
and they like
defund the police now those are just
three [__] words
guess what now people are defunding
police departments and people are seeing
what comes with that with 29 29 minute
911 call responses or whatever but i'm
not getting into the political terms
that [__] right now
what i'm getting into is how desperate
you have to be to do something like that
that was the desperation i was living
around
and that was the desperation that i had
to get away from
i mean you think about that that just
i had 20 jesse smellets around me on a
daily basis
not men not particular women not
particular man i'm not putting anybody
down
i'm just saying that you know when
somebody comes up to you like you're not
going to believe this
i've got a pilot that might go with you
it's like this [__] desperation but
the jesse smellet thing i think was what
pushed me over
and let me know it was time for me to
leave
because it was so mind-boggling of a
thing that you set up
then they found the two africans going
to buy the rope and the [__] man i
mean they
these two guys weren't geniuses either
you know you have to go across
town you wouldn't go with the other guy
you'd have to wear a [__] disguise so
they couldn't catch it
you know you don't pay with a credit
card or pay with a check
i mean he even paid the guys with a
[__] check
everything he did in that move was
stupid
is he a stupid kid no not by no means
he just made a mistake i'm not here
putting them down
i'm telling you about the situation and
what made that
kid do that that day and it's called
being desperate as
[__] and i'm saying that's when you look
at me and you go oh
yeah joey's probably not getting high as
much joey's lifting joey
no that feeling around me
was crushing me as a [__] man that
weight was crushing me that i had people
around me that were ready to do that
at any time that was the girl that
sucked my dick at the comedy store you
think that was the first girl i went
down to the comedy store
to suck dick to get spots or for a comic
to take around the road
you're gonna hear a thousand [__]
stories listen the comedy story did a
documentary of it
and there was one thing i was proud of
that they threw in there
just so the people at home knew part of
that background
yeah misty [__] some of the comics for
stage time
was it stage time no it was that she was
a sexual [__] woman
she was a sexual beast if you looked at
her when she was younger
she was a piece of ass no disrespect to
paul or peter
i'm just telling you what i saw from you
know
the pictures or whatnot like that i
heard little stories i heard little
rumors
i i didn't have to eat a [__] to
[__] get spots
but if she came to me with an ultimatum
eat my [__] get spots
it's not like you're sucking somebody's
dick i'm going to take that [__] to the
grave jack
i'm going to call the jinyoung use out
of that [__] thing
i'm going to take half the [__] off as a
souvenir and bite i'm gonna get spots to
the end of the day
maybe i would have done it i don't know
i don't [__] know
but i just want to tell you about the
desperation that i lived around and one
of the things
that made me double take of where i was
living
because that was the common thread that
was the little air
is that desperation you know there were
little things happening that i would say
why the [__] is this happening
i did that show on showtime that was
based off
the comedy store whatever whatever the
[__] it was loosely it was jim carrey's
show he wasn't in it
he was the executive producer i recurred
i did like like three episodes it didn't
matter
i don't even know what i was gonna say
to you [__] it didn't matter
about
uh you know the three episodes or
whatever the [__] i did
uh i forgot what i was gonna say who the
[__] gives a [__]
it's towards the end anyway you know
what i'm saying i proved my point we
covered [__] uh
we covered a lot of things today how's
that for you we're coming [__]
we come with mitzi's muffler we covered
jesse stillett we covered [__]
addiction we covered it all but no
what i'm trying to say to you people was
that was i did that show for
uh each uh showtime and i forget they
had a little wrap party
and i remember going to the wrap party
guys and it was a monday night and i
told my wife you know what let's do a
date night
let's get the babies out take you with
me i haven't gone pulling these things
these people were nice enough to put me
in that [__] show
like the least i could do is just go
down there and [__] uh
be a gentleman and you know let me tell
you something
i walked in there as i was leaving i saw
jim carrey i mean i didn't go to the sea
gym carry or whatever
in my life i saw jim carrey like two or
three times
i never had a conversation with him or
anything
but it was so funny i was standing there
and i meet these [__] hors d'oeuvres
or whatever the [__] that they had
and i'm talking to my wife i'm looking
at my wife i'm going look at all the
people that are here
this is a wrap party and the people that
were in the show
like i did my scenes with melissa leo
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with
you know uncle joey could work opposite
anybody [__]
so i did my scenes with melissa leo you
know
when i did my scene with her i didn't
really i talked to her a lot when we
were in the room
we talked about different movies she had
been in and
but i didn't get a chance to thank her
so i wanted to thank her
i went down there and just basically
just thanked the producers to put me in
the show
and to thank melissa leo for giving me a
[__] acting lesson that day in that
room
and i didn't see melissa leo you know i
didn't see her at all but
what i did see was 150 [__] people
that had nothing to do with the show
that was just there like hi
how are you and i'm like what are you
doing here were you in the show and i
wasn't trying to be mean to them or not
i would just say to him i didn't know
you were on the show and they would go
no we just got invited we crashed the
party and i'm like
what what is the point of you crashing
this
i'm dying to stand i'm dying up here the
stars are all here
santino's here eric griffin's here
[__] the little kid from almost
famous is here
the black dude is here they're the stars
of the show the girl the cute little
blonde
what the [__] are you doing here like
there were so many people
that didn't [__] belong there i'm
like this is what i'm talking about
why are you here what is the [__]
point here
so that was it part of that the [__]
jessie smilet thing
you know and again you're like joey
jesse smelled a year later
i want you to think about what that
[__] dude did
that's part of what lives in l.a that's
part of it
you know and he don't have a home look
at half of it is being desperate
and the other half is looking to fill
the hole that's why bikram yoga
that's why nexium and that's why
scientology
are [__] filthy rich because half of
them are desperate
and the other half you got to [__]
fill that [__] hole that whatever the
[__] happened to them
in their childhood or they got to be
friends with people or jump up and up
and down with white people and wait for
martians
i don't [__] get it i'm just happy to
be the [__] out of there
i miss my friends i miss california
i miss the uh weather i missed the
beaches i miss
everything about it but it was time to
move on and we're here i missed the
church
i miss lee but it's uncle joey's joined
now
and now we move forward and we're going
into 2021
and i'm just here to tell you one thing
guys i love you [__]
whether you're on patreon or not whether
you just support the podcast
whether you listen to it on apple
whether you're watching on [__]
itunes
or youtube whatever the [__] i'm saying
thank you very much for supporting me
i'm here for you guys we crack a few
jokes
we talk about a few [__] subjects and
we move the [__] on i'm not here to
waste your time
i'm just here to keep you above water
during these difficult [__] times
if you get a giggle if you can learn one
thing [__] it if not
tell me uncle joey go [__] yourself and
move on to a different podcast
but if you watch this today i'm [__]
happy i'm going to keep doing this
podcast
even with the knee surgery i'm gonna be
here christmas week when you need me the
most
because that's when people really get
down and there's nothing to be down
about guys
you're alive you're kicking you're not
in a [__] hospital
and even if you are you're not [__]
dead you got everything you need there's
people out there that are missing limbs
there's people out there that aren't
eating there's people out there that are
really having a hard time
if you're there sitting there feeling
sorry for yourself [__] that
uncle joey's here never fear you got the
world by the balls
and the world don't owe you nothing it's
time for you to get up and get out
2021 is here 20 20 was a wash
for everybody not just you everybody
went down the [__] toilet
so stop feeling sorry for yourself grab
that [__] joint
go grab your wife eat your [__] and
have a [__] great week all right
i'm happy you tuned in today to uncle
joey's joint
it is what it is in time when says
guests
and all this [__] we'll pick it up even
the [__]
it's even different getting difficult to
zoom with the [__] these days
covert is coming through the [__]
zoom so
we're here every monday and wednesday
if you want more uncle joey go to
patreon three
five ten dollars if you want merch it's
hopefully we get the shirts out to you
by christmas i'm working really hard
and beside that that's it and that's
that i show up on monday and wednesday
with nothing but love in my heart and
[__] nut juice in my nut sac
ready to give it all to you if you want
it you know what i'm saying and if you
don't want it just go
[__] it switch the channel i want to
thank you guys
i want to thank you all the guys on
patreon i want to thank you guys that
watch
i want to thank the guys that buy
tickets i'm sorry if we couldn't come to
your town this year
all these tours got canceled i'm [__]
sorry
but guess what i'm getting my knees
[__]
and i'm gonna be [__] stronger and
better than i ever was
and i'm gonna tour till i have a fat
little [__] heart attack on stage
i don't give a [__] so sit down
relax this will soon fast uncle joey's
got you
try to make the best of what you got i
love you [__]
and i'll see you on monday morning tip
top magoo
or i'll see you on patreon now for a
word
from our sponsors all right i want to
thank all you [__]
for listening for supporting for the
love for everything you give to me you
know i love you guys
with all my [__] heart whether
you're here with the um patreon it don't
matter to me
i know things are rough but before we go
i want to talk to you people about
something
listen right now it's the season for
some people forgiving some people out
there
buying things [__] that [__] if you
listen to the joint we're here for the
[__] thinking all right
we're looking to make some [__]
getters and draftkings is coming in
with the [__] big envelope they got
odds boost
they got promotions they got the best
lines in the nfl ncaa
and ufc every single day this [__]
week this is the week to make the money
right here
starts tonight you got wisconsin you got
back you got college basketball tonight
rolling into nfl roll into cotton and a
little bit every night
you don't got to be a [__] animal
okay
you're just trying to build your
bankroll two one let's say you get five
plays by the end by sunday and you get
three net winners
right you go three and [__] uh two
you still got one that winning you still
made money for the week and that's the
bottom line
is making money and that's what
draftkings does for you right now if you
sign up tonight you're going to get a
chance to triple your winnings
when you make any bet on the ufc fight
this saturday
figure it a doe versus moreno all right
get three times any bet
this week on ufc 256 that's a [__]
real deal right there
plus all new players get a chance to
earn a sign up bonus of a thousand
dollars
a thousand dollars you get it with code
joey j-o-e-y
and if you haven't signed up yet bang
your head against the wall 10 times
because now is the time to make some
[__] money so your kids could [__]
eat
and you get your dick sucked this year
like who don't want the dick sucking on
christmas day
like some chick with a [__] santa hat
on raise your hand right now
yeah you're a half a [__] [__]
everybody wants their dicks up
and you're not gonna get your dick
something if you're not [__] making
any guinness
and i'm giving you a part-time job right
here what are you gonna uh bought a
bicycle
go [__] yourself draftkings
[__]
download the top rated draftking
sportsbook app now
use promo code joey when you sign up you
get a thousand dollars
a thousand dollars to start with are you
[__] nuts or what
that's code joey to get a deposit bonus
for limited time only at draftkings
sportsbook
you got to be 21 and older this is what
the lawyers make me say
so i got to tell you [__] new
jersey indiana pennsylvania
all these new states like lua tennessee
colorado
that all of you [__] deposit
bonus of a thousand dollars requires a
25-time playthrough that's the whole
month of december that's like stealing
and we're going to make some [__]
money you got both games you got
everything
restrictions do apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details you got a gaming
problem
there's help don't be a [__]
degenerate [__] next thing you
know
you're at otb getting [__] under the
counter you don't want to do that
but if you got a problem call 1-800
gambler
and if you're in indiana call 1-800-9
with it
but if you don't got any problems
everything is all right and you got a
[__] bet like i'm telling you to bet
like a gentleman
you're going to [__] make some money
but first you got to download
the draftking sportsbook app use code
joey
and cashing on some [__] money this
week all right that's how we're starting
a party
number two cbd line you want to feel
good
you wake up in the mornings you're a
little duddy like uh
i don't know what i'm gonna do i know
what you're gonna do you take a shower
you're gonna wash your balls and you're
gonna take yourself three little
cbd gummies by cbd lion whether you got
the raspberry the strawberry the
tropical
you [__] don't lose three of those
little gummy bears okay you put a little
pep in your step and if you got a
particular pain they got kinesiology
tape
they got the roll on for your shoulders
or your knees or your elbows
or your nut sack i don't know what's
hurting but cbd lion's here to help
we also have a vapor we have a beautiful
they just got a beautiful dark chocolate
you eat a piece of that in the morning
we could all go for dark chocolate in
our lives it's like red wine
but the party starts when you go to
cbdlion.com
read up on cbd cbn you trust some
[__] guy with a ged
behind the counter at a gas station what
the [__] are you [__]
let's go to cbdlion.com right now and
press in code joey
or church and they're going to give you
20 off delivered to your [__] house
all right
who takes care of you like uncle joey on
wednesday
two or three weeks before [__]
christmas nobody
i love you cox tucker stay black have a
great weekend and we'll be back monday
with a big dick and a neck brace you
know what i'm saying
let's do this [__] i love you hot
suckers stay black
there you go can't those done i take a
[__] hike
you